sabemos que si tenemos tres puntos no
alineados en el plano entonces existe un
único triángulo que pasa por esos tres
puntos por ejemplo si este es el punto a
este el b y este el c entonces hay un
único punto que tiene a abc como
vértices y para construirlo simplemente
trazamos los segmentos a b b c y c a
bueno pero además sabemos que si tenemos
un triángulo entonces existe un único
punto que es equidistante a los tres
vértices y para construir ese punto lo
que tenemos que hacer es trazar las tres
media tristes de los lados y como ya
vimos en vídeos anteriores estas siempre
se van a interceptar en un único punto o
bien se van a cortar en un único punto y
ese punto es el que nos interesa es el
punto equidistante a a b y c entonces
déjame trazar las media tristes aquí en
la media triz de ave más o menos déjame
dar a la herramienta de línea más o
menos sería algo así
va entonces es una recta que es
perpendicular al ave y pasa por su punto
medio este es igual a éste luego la
media triz de veces sería más o menos
así
algo de este estilo quizás un poco más
para acá así se ve bien entonces otra
vez aquí es perpendicular y pasa por el
punto medio éste es igual a este de acá
y finalmente la media triste hace sería
algo de este estilo vale pasaría pasaría
por el punto medio va a ser un poco más
derechista pasaría por el punto medio de
hace entonces éste es igual a éste y
sería perpendicular a hace bueno ahí
están las tres media tristes y el punto
en el cual se intersectan le llamamos o
y es el círculo centro del triángulo le
llamamos el círculo centro del triángulo
entonces o es el circo un centro cirque
un centro todo esto parece un repaso
pero ahorita nos va a llevar algunas
ideas interesantes vale bueno este punto
o que es el círculo centro justo es el
punto que equidista de los tres vértices
es decir hago es igual a veo y esto es
igual a c
entonces déjame escribirlo por acá
es igual a veo que es igual a cero y a
esta distancia que es igual para este
par este y para este le llamamos el
circo un radio sin radio
radio bueno y esto nos llevaba a otra
idea interesante verdad porque cada que
tenemos un punto en el plano y una
distancia entonces existe una única
circunferencia que tiene a este punto
como centro ya esta distancia como radio
vale es más déjame hago por acá deja
deja algo por acá un dibujo entonces si
tenemos por ahí un centro y tenemos una
distancia a r entonces existe una única
circunferencia que tiene a este punto
como centro y a esa distancia r como
radio y lo que acaba sucediendo es que
esta circunferencia es el conjunto de
puntos que están a distancia r de el
centro entonces todas estas longitudes
son r r y r bueno con esto en mente
podríamos aplicar esta idea acá ya
tenemos un centro tenemos un radio y
entonces podemos considerar la
circunferencia con centro en popa y con
radio
y entonces esa circunferencia debe de
pasar por los tres vértices déjame ver
si la puedo dibujar con la herramienta
de círculo y que quede más o menos
decente entonces quedaría algo de este
estilo muy bien quedó muy bonita
ok entonces ya tenemos la circunferencia
pasa por los tres vértices todo esto es
un repaso pero vamos a juntar todas las
ideas que tenemos para ver que hay una
idea bonita detrás de todo esto entonces
lo que dijimos es que si tenemos tres
puntos tres puntos no alineados no
alineados
entonces existe un único triángulo que
tiene esos puntos como vértice entonces
único
único único triángulo que tiene esos
tres puntos como vértices pero este
triángulo tiene un único circo un centro
y un único circo un radio vale entonces
tiene un único único circo un centro
un centro y tiene un único único circo
un radio
radio y un radio bueno y si tenemos un
centro y un radio entonces con eso
podemos construir una única única
circunferencia sí
herencia circunferencia va entonces a
esa única circunferencia le llamamos el
circo un círculo o bien la
circunferencia circunscrita pero bueno o
sea esto lo que nos dice es lo siguiente
nos dice que cada vez que tenemos tres
puntos en el plano entonces existe una
única circunferencia que pasa por esos
tres puntos y eso está bien interesante
pero lo que está todavía más interesante
es que es lo mínimo que necesitamos si
sólo tuviéramos dos puntos digamos aquí
un punto xy aquí un punto y entonces
estos no bastan para determinar una
circunferencia porque en realidad estos
dos puntos podrían hacer muchos
triángulos verdad podrían hacer digamos
este triángulo o
bueno que era un poco chueco pero bueno
podrían hacer ese triángulo o bien este
triángulo de acá o quizás uno por abajo
vale uno por abajo por acá entonces
todos estos triángulos pues bueno
parecería que tienen un centros
distintos y el con radios distintos y
entonces en realidad hay varias
circunferencias que pasan por equis y
por jay bueno esta idea está interesante
ahora quiero mostrarte otra idea que
también está bien padre una pregunta que
nos podemos hacer es la siguiente
imagínate que ahora empezamos con un
circunferencia entonces ahí está un
punto y voy a trabajar me una
circunferencia cualquiera con ese punto
como centro vale y lo que vamos a hacer
ahora es tomar tres vértices sobre la
circunferencia entonces la pregunta es
la siguiente será cierto que el cirque
un centro del triángulo hecho por esos
tres vértices de adeveras es el centro
de la circunferencia está interesante la
pregunta verdad está padre vamos vamos a
jugar un poco con la pregunta para ver
si es cierto o sea parecería ser que sí
pero a lo mejor hay algunos casos que no
son tan intuitivo entonces vamos a hacer
el dibujo entonces digamos no sé
imagínate que tenemos aquí un punto un
punto a un punto a por acá un punto b y
vamos a hacer que el centro de la
circunferencia quede fuera del triángulo
a veces digamos que por acá que del
punto c vale entonces tenemos este
triángulo entonces la pregunta sera
bien la pregunta en este caso es será
cierto que el circo un centro de abc es
el centro de esta circunferencia pues
parecería ser que no oa lo mejor no no
no podemos estar tan seguros así
directamente porque para empezar está
fuera entonces como podría ser un centro
si está fuera del triángulo bueno pues
es algo importante no está dentro o si
está fuera sino ver si de adeveras está
sobre las tres media triz es verdad
entonces bueno para eso lo que vamos a
utilizar es que estoy aquí es una
circunferencia y como es una
circunferencia entonces todos todos los
puntos que están marcados en blanco
equidistante este punto de acá vale una
misma distancia r en particular a b y c
están a una cierta distancia r de este
punto de aquí entonces déjame marcar
estos segmentos este mide lo mismo que
éste y mide lo mismo que éste todos esos
miden un cierto radio r
r r r vale entonces observa a partir de
eso podemos ver que este punto que el
centro de la circunferencia está en
todas las media triz es porque por
ejemplo qué sucede si nos tomamos la
media triz del lado ave digamos esta de
acá que voy a pintar en color verde voy
a usar colores distintos para no
confundirnos
bueno pues esa media actriz tiene que
pasar por o porque como ya vimos en otro
vídeo cualquier punto que existe de ahí
debe pasa por la media triz de del
segmento ave
entonces en efecto o déjame llamarle en
el centro de esta circunferencia está en
la media triz de ave entonces esta de
aquí es la media triz aquí es recto y
éste es igual este de acá de manera
similar o tiene que estar en la media
triz de veces porque v es igual a 11 los
dos son iguales al radio entonces o
equidista dvd c y entonces como ya vimos
en el vídeo anterior
tenemos que o tiene que estar sobre la
media triz este efecto este efecto y
este de acá es igual a este de acá y
finalmente repitiendo el argumento para
hacer tenemos que o también debe estar
en la media triz d
ya hasta te vas a cansar del argumento
pero es la misma idea es igual a cero
porque son iguales al radio entonces o
equidista de a y de c y por lo tanto
concluimos concluimos déjame agarrar
otro color que está en la media triz de
hace vale entonces más o menos más o
menos es algo así más o menos es algo
así aquí es perpendicular perpendicular
y este de acá es igual a este de acá
vale entonces concluimos que está en las
tres media tristes y por lo tanto o en
efecto es decir un centro del triángulo
a bs y esta circunferencia es decir un
círculo o bien la circunferencia
circunscrita del triángulo a b c y en
realidad pues esta circunferencia puede
ser el círculo círculo de muchos
triángulos verdad aquí pitt el abc pero
también podríamos tener otro triángulo
por aquí abajo
digamos este con este con este ahí
tenemos otro triángulo con la misma
circunferencia circunscrita o podría ser
éste con éste
vale entonces esta circunferencia tiene
muchos triángulos de los cuales es
circunferencia circunscrita